today I'm here to go against everything
I've ever said on my channel and to ask
you guys to please stop meeting
strangers for now let's just let's take
a little break I know things suck right
now and everything feels really weird
like it's hard to put into words how I
feel like the other day I just started
crying for no reason like literally
nothing had happened
I was just sitting there and I started
crying I keep zoning out multiple times
a day and when I snapped back into it I
can't remember what I was thinking about
like are you guys going through this as
well as it's just me at least every
night I have a nightmare and when I wake
up it feels like I'm waiting to wake up
from another nightmare but I never do
this must be a little weird because my
channel is about other people and I
never share anything about myself but
I'm doing that today to show that we're
all in this together and to emphasize
the importance of what I'm about to ask
you guys to do the kindest thing you
could do for yourself the people you
love and strangers you'll never meet is
to follow the protocols social
distancing please please stay away from
social settings
wash your hands don't touch your face I
know this is hard because we're all
social beings trust me I would know I
meet about 400 new people every week but
it's really important that we do this
when you're at a store and you want to
grab the last two hand sanitizers just
remember that the stranger next to you
is just a scared and in need of the hand
sanitizer
so take one leave one for them something
common I just touched my face something
common I've been hearing from young
people is that they shouldn't be worried
because coronavirus isn't gonna kill
them but what about your mom and your
grandparents and like people who have a
compromised immune system if you're not
worried about yourself please keep in
mind the people who are the most
vulnerable I already know some people
are gonna say that people like me are
overreacting and that there is no need
for videos like this and I hope you're
right honestly I hope that in a month
all the comments on this video are
making fun of how much I over yeah
at about the coronavirus because that
would mean that there was some sort of a
solution by then I genuinely hope that's
the case but if that's not the case then
I couldn't I couldn't live with myself
knowing that I could have done more I
honestly do think that our actions right
now could literally save lives and we
can all be heroes I know we always
imagined heroic acts as like jumping in
front of a car to push someone out of
the way but just think now you don't
have to risk your own life to save
someone else's life in fact you might
even be saving your life as well so it's
just way cooler with that said I will
continue to post every Thursday here on
my channel meeting these strangers I'm
just kidding I'm not I'm not meeting
strangers anymore face to face at least
instead I'll be asking you guys to send
in videos or to send me your number so I
could FaceTime you and I'll announce the
topic for that week's episode either on
here on my youtube channel in the
community section or on my Instagram and
my twitter mainly my Instagram I still
don't really know how to use Twitter I
think it's important with everything
that's happening for the first topic we
discussed to be the coronavirus so if
you've personally been affected by the
corona virus and you're willing to share
your story please email me at the riot
project at gmail.com yeah that's all
guys thank you for everything
be kind stay safe I love you all and
I'll see you next Thursday
you